so you see where I come from we like to
take our time with the ladies you know
it's called being a gentleman
that's why I refuse to look Brittany on
Hill I refuse to look in her general
direction till marriage is she pretty
just like not or some I really like
bread she actually reminds me of my best
friend back home my mom we had such a
good time in the jacuzzi day - it was
like so warm and inviting and comforting
it's almost like being back in the womb
or something oh if only yeah it's cool
that everyone's trying to play nice but
I'm here to win straight up that's why I
gave everyone lice including myself your
boys up to special killing it yeah I
felt the group date went really well
even though I didn't get to talk to
Britt as much as I would have liked
David what's that you've already been
eliminated
I've been eliminated before the rose
ceremony
uh-huh I've only caught a glimpse of
Bernie but boy let me tell you that's a
good-looking name insurance butter with
that me here numbs a so dangerous let me
back in there it burns so bad you got an
ass knee I won't give up on love I would
I will maybe pause love for a bit
because the nice gentleman I forgot my
iPhone believe it look
you